you're all about entertainment I want to
entertain the audience all right let's
play a good old-fashioned game of rock
paper scissor I'll say one two three
shoot the winner gets to make the first
point you ready
one two three shoot Double Rock here it
is I think we agree more all right one
two three shoot
what a gentleman uh fees hit the Rocks
you hit the scissors he's won and he
allowed her to go perspective
I wanted to know from a business
perspective would you encourage someone
to sign a contract that the other person
benefits from breaking
from a business yeah if you took like
like from a business perspective
so if I had a business partner who could
break the contract and then what does
Breaking Me and they were they would
benefit they could take your most
valuable asset and if they broke the
contract they could take your most value
so if if I signed a contract and my
business partner can take my most
valuable asset I wouldn't sign that
contract continue okay that's marriage
today if you believe your kids are your
most valuable asset and I think and I
think that's more of the red pill like I
would say that's more of why men are
walking away from Marriage today I love
this so let's let's stay here because
this is a fantastic I have two questions
first
um out of you in your personal opinion
this is a separate question what is your
goal for your channel like what is what
are you trying to do what is your pro
what is your purpose for doing pearly
things what is my purpose
um I would say it's mostly entertainment
so just so you want to entertain yeah
and then I started the wife school
because I was like I really think as
women we should listen to what the men
are saying and then yeah so your show
which I did start by the could I please
get the no no no no no no I promise you
I wanted to do this shout you out for
doing the wife school and I saw parts of
the first episode I like it was classy I
like what you're doing so I'm gonna give
you I told you when you do it I'm gonna
give you your props shout you out Pro
for real for doing the right things can
help a lot of people so let's go ahead
and talk about this but I just think I I
like entertainment because I feel like
in entertainment you can tell the like
like sneaker always says you tell about
the the truth about the world through
funny and I just think I was like that's
so true so okay like I feel like
comedians are like almost but Adam you
mind if I just I'm just gonna I'm gonna
stay right there
it's not just entertainment
entertainment you could do video games
like it's entertainment with a mix of
what oh with a mix of like red pill
Concepts okay yeah so it's it's red pill
entertainment I just try not to
because there's so many guys that I just
think are like Geniuses in the space you
know what I mean I just look up to them
a lot so I just try not to like
you know there's people that are like
researchers they're like very end you
know gotcha so it's not just
entertainment because there's a lot of
entertainment respect go ahead of Peace
So to me the the business analogy you
gave was totally irrelevant to any form
of marriage conversation because here's
a fundamental reality if a man wants to
have a child whether he has a baby mama
whether he has a wife whether he has a
girlfriend whether he has a fiance
whether he has a rando if she wants to
take away custody of the child under
certain circumstances she can so what
people in the red pill to me do is a
straw man that they say oh if you get
married she can take away your kids but
if you hook up with girl down the street
she has your kid there's no there's no
chance of taking it away and so to me
putting that on marriage is a is a false
um correlation putting that on the laws
today if you're gonna if you're gonna
say the loss today okay but that's not a
marriage problem because in the black
community 70 of people are born in
single mother households they're not
even getting married in the black
community and that's a huge problem so
going back to what I was saying my
desire is to help build up society and
to give men the tools to which where
your family doesn't end in divorce but
here's the reality if you don't get
married and you have a child you've lost
a child there's no chance and with going
back to statistics if you do the
statistics if you're prepared there's no
guarantee but you you greatly improve
your odds so you can be like Pearl's dad
and my dad to raise your child but if
you're just gonna have a if you're not
gonna get married
it's not the case so my question to you
is 63 according to the um the the Bureau
of Labor
statistics and also census data we can
pull it up later 63 percent of men over
the age of 15 have a child so Mom say
that again so Natalia you can go through
the data real quick because I want to be
63 of men over the age of 15. scroll
down
scroll down scroll down scroll down
scroll up up up men are fathers right
there
should be right there yes so um we can
go ahead and scroll down right here
first is up up up up up up up up up up
up up purple right there about 61 of men
70.4 74.7 million men ages 15 and over
our fathers and of those 72.2 million
men have a biological child according to
the new men's fertility fatherhood 2014
report released today by the Census
Bureau so most men
are going to be fathers most men want to
have children my question to you is if
marriage is a bad idea for men what do
you tell the most men who are going to
have children what should they do I
don't
care like your Channel's advice of these
I don't advise men on how to live their
lives what I'm saying is you should be
aware of the laws today and and make a
decision accordingly and I think a lot
of times like when the red pill would
say this law that law this like girls
are like this this and this it's they're
just warning you so and you can do what
you want with the information so I love
it so I'm saying it depends on the guy
so my question to you because I want to
talk to H not Pearl the YouTuber I want
to talk to h no H's I know H is let's
talk to H okay so I don't know age yeah
she knows who H is H my question my
question my question is if a man came up
to you say yo I love you I love your
channel I love what you do I just want a
piece of advice I know marriage is a bad
idea but I want to have children what
can you give me any piece of advice what
would you give that man personally I
don't give advice do you tell them
nothing I gotta go I would say you
should talk to the men in your life like
I just don't consider myself someone to
like gives advice like that's not my
channel my channel
but I'm saying that's not me as I don't
I'm not giving advice what if your son
asked you that question I said mommy
talk to your dad okay I love it so the
point but it's interesting guys have a
lot of interesting ways that they kind
of try to get around it so like one I
think his name's Aaron Cleary I think
that's who it is he has his girlfriend
pay the rent and like like and they
don't actually get legally married so
there's there's some loss we can like
avoid wait his girlfriend pays his rent
yeah like legally so her name's on the
lease and everything so but then she can
leave
what do you mean if his girlfriend pays
the rent and they haven't have a kid he
can leave she can leave
same problem what do you mean so you
said no I'm saying so she legally can't
seize his assets but in the case that's
what I was saying so she so men have
different ways of getting around the
laws today I'm talking about the
fatherhood thing because your business
example was losing your most precious
asset the most precious asset as you
communicate with me was a child so my
question to you is that for men who want
to have children as most men want to
have children what would you say as an
individual so what happens Adam that
I've noticed a lot of times in the space
is they don't answer the question so my
question is if we're giving but I I
don't give advice and that's what I'm
saying like my channel is entertainment
so you're saying give advice why don't
you give it but like that's not what I
do to me if we're two human beings I
just want to know what's true what's
untrue so and you can you could say like
and the point is the laws are bad for
men we don't even disagree on this but
but you're like you got like I want to
tell you guys how to do your channel
I mean you told me that last time when
you're telling me how to do wife school
and that's what like a lot of people in
in the on the other side will criticize
us and be like well you should do it
this way you should do it this way but
our job a lot of people is entertainment
mine is mainly entertainment other
people have entertainment and education
it just depends on the channel but I
think it's important we have a million
channels of all the things that like
women want from men and the problems
with men there's a million stuff but
then when the men do it it's like we
have to criticize and say and say that
they're not doing it in the right way uh
listen I believe all the men who are
creating content to help men I love it I
love it I love every single thing all
I'm asking for is once we know about the
problems of women today which we do they
can go to a difference
please maybe okay
so so since you said please thank you so
much you're so kind to me so to me all
I'm all I'm saying is that I just asked
you that question as an individual
there's nothing to do with your channel
I would just I was genuinely curious
your position if you were to give
someone advice one of the biggest things
that I want that I do is I want to give
men the best solutions to be successful
and what I find in in finance advice
right if someone's having a fine a
channel to help people financially right
you have to give them some pieces of
advice of here are best practices to do
to be able to optimize your finances so
one of the biggest things is that when
it comes to the fatherhood question I'm
just very curious from a red pills
perspective for a majority of men who
want to have children what are you
telling those individuals to do and if
there's no advice then are they just
lost do you think that women like men
should listen to a woman more or a man
when it comes to advice a hundred
thousand percent amen I agree I'm not
talking so I'm not even personally I'm
saying even in a personal situation I
agree I think men should advise other
men yes so so I'm saying this question
is kind of pointless yeah because
because even in person like I just think
men teach men better okay so if I can
answer like yeah I feel like I feel like
you do have an answer and I feel like
your answer is very simple I think it's
buyer beware just be aware of what's
going to happen you don't have to be an
advice person to be like look before you
get married just buy or beware I think
that's something that you could you you
would abide by I do want to give you
credit on one thing because when she
ask the question if you're going to get
into business with somebody and you're
going to sign a contract but then your
business partner can basically screw you
over and take your business would you
sign that contract you're like hell no I
wouldn't sign that contract I was like
oh damn my face what's up you got you
right but then I think what you're the
point you made was actually uh very
astute you said Hey listen you don't
have to get married to have a kid you
could you could knock up the girl on the
street it can be your baby mom it could
be a girlfriend there's a million
different things and the reality is men
are having kids so
whatever the red pill teaches you or
whatever anybody teaches you there's no
way to prevent the crazy girl that you
knocked up from doing something to take
your kid away okay your asset so I guess
what is your advice because Pearl's not
going to answer this and I respect the
fact that she's like I'm not a dude I
can't answer it so I don't want to
belabor the point you want to have kids
one day of course okay
um so what advice would you give men so
what's really interesting about this
conversation is one of the things is I'm
always trying to give men opinion a lot
of this advice would give behind the
scenes I honestly I'm going to give one
piece of advice but I don't give all the
advice I don't want anyone watching it
and changing some of the laws so when
you really study custody laws and I've
been studying recently when do men get
custody one of the primary reasons why
women win custody battles is because
women spend more child with spend more
time with the child when it's younger so
what did what the divorce um from myself
a lot of times you have to breastfeed
yeah I mean that's just so what the
judge is going to do is the judge wants
to continue to stop the the child's
standard of living right so the judge
wants to ensure that the child his
living is not disrupted very much so if
the child is spending 90 percent of the
time hypothetically speaking with the
mom because Dad is going to work and
she's taking care of it taking taking it
to the hospital different things like
that they're going to award it so one of
the things that I've noticed when I a
lot of my friends who've actually
received custody one of the things that
they did is that they've made sure that
they spend equal amount of time with the
child as much as possible during infancy
so there's a lot of small things you can
do I one if um knowing all your child's
doctors go as best as possible being
able to go to the doctor's visits to
late at night when a child is up you
take care of the child as well so and
then the third thing which is the most
important thing is to be able to have
that child be very accustomed to your
family so instead of you know the child
um her her mom babysitting if your
family is babysitting If the child is
always around your family and in a
natural um uh and and the most
consistent environment the child is
being around is your personal family
it's very hard for you to have zero
custody and so those are some of the
things that I've noticed some of the
things I researched and it's a lot more
things as as well and the reason why
only reason I brought that up is because
it's so easy Adam and everyone does this
cop out I don't give advice I'm Charles
Barkley I don't give advice I don't give
advice I just give you the information
but you don't give all the information
so you don't give all the so you just
give some of the information but my
biggest 90 percent
excuse me ninety percent of the time
they don't get custody only five states
have 50 50 custody laws so so I
understand there's reasons for it but
but
let me finish Pro because you
interrupted me so what happens is if 90
so my thing is less analyze the data why
do they get custody right and then give
men the tools say hey guys here are
seven whenever these guys go to the
um go to the divorce court or whatever
custody court and they lose here's the
things that they say now men use this to
be able to improve your life and to
protect you recently one of my guys had
a child out of wedlock he was very
heartbroken by it we got him with a
lawyer we connected them with
information and we told them exactly
what he needs to do to protect himself
as much as possible it is so easy to
just say I give the information but so
many men need additional support and my
biggest thing is that I want to give men
the tools to win if that's not other
people that's other people but what I
want in the future is let's give men
more to schools to win at life instead
of just pointing about the issues today
which is fine your self-improvement
channel that's fine and but that's what
I'm saying there's different roles for
different people so okay be a
self-improvement channel that's fine
does it feel like it's like why are you
going to these people and saying this is
how you should run your channel these
people
that you just were saying this is what
we should do when did I say that
literally the last episode we should be
giving advice or you should I we should
we want to give people the tools okay so
you are you told me you're giving the
people the tools that's what you just
said you're giving the people Tuesday
free to do with it what they want that's
what you just said no I said my channel
is about entertainment that's what I
said no not you but you said in regards
to Red Pill you said they're just giving
people the facts to give them the tools
the study of human behavior yeah
but let's not get lost in this sauce
so to me my the biggest thing is that
what I'm really excited about Adam and I
would love to spend more time doing this
is that there's so many men today who
are hurting going through difficulties
going through obstacles they want to
make money we I love what you're doing
about making money they want to have a
family they want to be able to live a
legacy let's give those men more tools
and let's give men more practical advice
that's my rule of thumb let's learn from
men who have healthy marriages men like
your father men like Patrick David I've
learned so much about parenting and
being a husband from Patrick and Dr
Peterson so to me I'm all about let's
give the men Solutions because just
simply knowing about the problem does
not give you a better life and that's
what I want to see all of us do in this
conference I mean I think I think
knowing about the problem can help men
avoid mistakes in the future so I think
self-improvement's fine that's if you
want self-improvement that's great but
red pill is the study of human behavior
so that's Logistics so let's clarify
let's clarify so let's say red pill is a
study of human behavior so let's say we
have a red pill alien right so alien yes
could we play the game okay okay so we
have a red pill alien right so all he
wants to do is study human behavior Adam
human behavior I assume it's going to be
men and women right so therefore if the
man was just studying the alien was just
studying human behavior he will study
the behavior of men and behavior of
women he would study the good in men and
the good in women the badded men the bad
and women the uglian men the ugly women
he will do both so to me what you would
see if it's truly a study of human
behavior is what Dr David butts did so I
would challenge anyone to read any red
pill book and then read evolution of
Desire by Dr David read any of the
understanding human sexuality textbooks
and they do a great job The Good The Bad
and ugly men the good bad uglier women
first is what I've seen happen at times
with some content creators where it's
literally 90 percent women so to me if
you're calling if you're calling it The
study of female nature I love it but
let's not call the study of human nature
because it's not equally criticized in
both parties
um I would like to say they've talked
about things like saying that women are
socially inapped to men so I've heard
them say positive things about women I
mean you know the internet works the
more controversial stuff negative things
about women
you said that they don't study both
sides the good and the bad so they
equally studying both sides
certain things go viral more are they
equally studying both sides yes or no I
would say that yeah the research and
develop yes okay so I would challenge
anyone go to any red pill channel to go
to the past 40 videos analyze all those
videos and tell me what the topic is
about watch the video tell me the theme
and tell me which one they're studying I
mean I mean I also would like to say
like there's a million channels that
talk about what women want for men and
vice versa it's just not the same so I
think again the red pill
the the stuff about women go viral more
because it's just not that time
don't interrupt me I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry
let's just make a rule here if someone's
speaking make your point but make it
quick so the other person doesn't feel
the need to interrupt that's for both of
you Pearl you go and fees don't
interrupt when when a Visa speaking
don't interrupt and I will just I don't
that way I don't even need to talk you
guys do your thing so Pearl it's your
turn
um so yeah I lost my train of thought I
forgot yeah but I think I was just
saying like again the the stuff about
men is known more I would say than about
women so that that's why that stuff goes
viral because this type of content is
new
um but they if you look if you read it
like yeah they study both sides here's
what I want to do there's like 10 more
topics I want to get to I feel like
we've spent a lot of time talking about
the pros the cons of marriage pros and
cons of red pill respect I feel like you
guys are doing great do me a favor just
dap each other up real quick just so we
can just get one dab this is it men and
women that's black and white that's it
that's up and we're all here yes amazing
rainbow
um Pearl what I want to actually talk to
you about is this is something that I'm
very obsessed with these days is the
role of a man and a role of a woman in
as many of you know I was just banned on
talk and
I was on a daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible